I don't know if you were following the
action but Sabi and Wesley have been
knocked out did you follow the matches
there
yeah it's
just the kids now
did you miss Hikaru in this event
I didn't really think about that I feel
like I played pretty strong players in
the last uh last couple of
um of games but um yeah I mean in
general
um in all these formats it's been among
the very best probably second best
player in the world so any event that he
doesn't play in is slightly slightly
weaker what do you say to yourself
and a difficult
different techniques like the two main
techniques are one just trying to to
hold and the second is trying to hold by
creating counter play and like knowing
which one to use where is kind of the
key to defensive techniques if you're
talking about the position I had in game
two today
um well first of all I didn't know that
it was losing so that that helped even
though I did suspect that it was was a
pretty bad position but yeah I was just
trying to trying to hold on play as well
as I I could the position was so
complicated that
um you try to do your best thing
I've seen this so many times Magnus you
not only have this incredible ability to
convert winning positions almost
flawlessly uh but also be able to turn
around and win worse positions how do
you do it how do you do it better than
others
[Music]
I don't think I do though
I'm getting out of worse positions than
I am
um so um I think there are even stats on
that that when it comes to like
scrambling in worse positions and I'm
like I'm okay but I'm not one of the
best and I think the reason is that I
don't have that much experience being
worse so yeah
I actually I usually play from a
position of strength so people
uh people like Hikaru for instance who
often gets in Broad positions he
uh he defends them extremely well and
extremely resourcefully
um and um to be fair all the rest as
well
um
yeah I think yeah I'm not really one of
the best when it comes to that